wearable technology like the Apple watch
it's gonna have it today we know it's
day is coming the Apple watch is coming
in January and that this type of stuff
is gonna you know stick around for a
little while but that ultimately this is
all going to the technology being
embedded in us so they had an
interesting article that we're gonna
link to right down below with 9
technologies that are going to be part
of our human body and we're gonna go
through a couple of them right now
the first implantable smartphone yeah
that looks a little scary hopefully
they're gonna get it to the place where
it's not going to be that obvious but
scientists are working on AI implants
that let an image be captured with the
blink and transmitted to any local
storage images might be displayed
through artificial skin in your eye
implants alright so hopefully you're not
gonna be a giant patch of discolored
skin on your arm but I guess getting the
phone actually embedded into us at this
point it kind of seems obvious doesn't
it like the watch to me almost seems
ridiculous at this point because it's
going to do less than the thing we have
in our pocket so just putting the phone
in us it's coming right yeah I mean I
don't think it's a bad thing I mean
think about the the degree to which
we've bonded psychologically with our
technology I mean we haven't yet bonded
physically but we will it's coming and I
think that you know it's I think only
good stuff is gonna come of that it's
gonna allow us to measure you know an
amazing and infinite number of you know
biometric qualities which we can then
use to improve so I'm excited for the
health implications right well I'm gonna
get to my robots are taking over later
but I know you're you're going positive
to start the next one cyber pills that
we'll talk to your doctor a British
research team is developing cyber pills
with micro processors that context
doctors directly from inside your body
so basically you'll have these things
inside of you and if there's something
wrong with one of your organs or
something the doctors will find out
immediately that that seems pretty good
right technology can kind of help with
with the health stuff right
as long as my cyber pill doesn't get
spammed a lot of calls on my cell phone
offering me carpet cleaning and you know
virus protection yeah
cyber you're down with this this help
your ear into the medical stuff yeah I
mean
I've been lately obsessed with the
microbiome have you guys heard of that
it's basically the universe of
microorganisms that live in your gut
that outnumber your own cells ten to one
and there it's got so many implications
on our health outcomes that it's just
like mind-blowing and we're just at the
very tip of the iceberg in terms like
understanding the interplay between that
and our health wait does this have
something to do with the the poop thing
that everybody we got to do a story on
that can you break it down in like two
sentences yes basically yes so there's
there's a bacterial infection that kills
I think 14,000 people in the u.s. yearly
for which there is no cure and they
found that they found a cure and that
cure is really gross fecal transplants
and yeah yeah and it's good it's a very
rudimentary way of tinkering with the
microbiome of these people that have
these kinds of infections by basically
replacing what they have going on with a
help with the microbiome of a healthy
person and so this is what it looks like
today in five years from now it's not
gonna be that it's gonna be like
specific you know bacteria that can then
help but again we're at the very sort of
beginning of all this stuff and I think
having you know those kinds of you know
smart pills that you can swallow and
analyze what's going on and your
intestines I think that's like that's
really cool yeah all right let's move on
to smart tattoos researchers have
crafted an implantable skin mesh of
computer fibers thinner than a human
hair that can monitor your body's inner
workings from the surface a chip has
been made that can be embedded in a
finger through a tattoo like process
letting you unlock things or enter code
simply by pointing so I thought this one
was kind of interesting because just
this week Apple pay was released and
this is just what you're gonna do on
your phone but soon enough it's gonna be
your finger so we all saw this coming
right once they started with the touch
ID that was just the one step for your
fingerprint and then Apple pay so the
next thing is just its own oh now
muggers will be cutting your hand off
that's correct
well it might not do report remember
they had to take the eye out too I mean
you know it all makes sense right I mean
just think about like the eye watch
that's something that we've got to
actually like strap on our wrists that
tattoo could potentially make it
something that we have on earth on us
all the time yeah so all right let's
move on
smart duh
two full computers each much smaller
than a grain of sand that can organize
themselves inside the body into as
needed networks to power a whole range
of complex internal processes with smart
dust doctors will be able to act inside
your body without opening you up this
one's going a little bit over my head I
just sort of kept picturing like those
scenes in the matrix where you just see
the matrix like create something am i
how off am I on this one you got
anything I mean this is the dawn of the
nanotech revolution right like we're
gonna be able to materialize things from
thin air we're doing it sort of with 3d
printing and it's a very sort of
rudimentary form but I think it's you
know it's just it's basically
capitalizing on the fact that technology
is becoming infinitely smaller faster
and cheaper and so eventually we'll be
able to like inhale smart robots that
repair cellular data things like that I
mean two issues one our cell phones
already giving us all cancer like I mean
do we really want one actually inside of
our body there I don't got all the bad
things at the end the other thing being
of course is that people are already
walking into traffic looking at this
crap I like now they're gonna be staring
at there are I mean I just I don't know
because their eyes will be replaced with
something that will see you'll see
they'll be watching traffic is the
problem I just for one feel like I
always want to embrace the idea of what
people call the technology Shabbat you
know where they take one day of the week
where they turn off all their screens
and they don't go online and they don't
check their texts and I can't do it I
would like to but I haven't gotten there
yet but I mean once it's in you you're
that there's there is no Shabbat ever
like it is you are constantly connected
yeah don't eat ham on that day all right
one more for you the verified self the
US military has serious programs to
equip soldiers with implanted RFID chips
so keeping track of troops becomes
automatic and worldwide this technology
could be used to ID every single human
being so this one doesn't seem that off
to me I mean I could see this obviously
there's military purposes but now let's
get to some of the the scary stuff so
then we already have this whole Big
Brother
anything so now we are going to be
walking around with this stuff where
we'll be able to be ID'd all the time
they will be able to track us all the
time it's not just going to be the
device it's gonna be built in us so as
someone that loves technology and I love
all this stuff too but I always for what
I watch a lot of sci-fi movies so I
always veer to that place where
something is gonna go wrong with it can
you give me some comfort in all this
stuff I mean I think that there are
always gonna be speed bumps and hiccups
on the way to you know radical
transformation but you know I mean look
at the fappening you know that was that
was a horrible thing that happened to
these you know starlets due to them
having crazy amounts of personal
information on their phones right but
all the celebrities that got their naked
happening got it okay that was an awful
thing but I think that because of that
we're gonna have enhanced algorithms
better security features so I'm just
imagining the CD David Cronenberg
back-alley operations where people have
to get their little doohickey removed so
they can't be followed by the cops and
may be replaced with a dead person so
that they you know are off the grid now
see you've watched as many surprises
this is all like eXistenZ that's
happening here we're gonna ports on the
back of our spine or whatever you know
yeah this just gives me the creeps and
and what's hilarious is you know if you
go back and watch the first Charlie's
Angels movie the the big bad guys plan
is that he's gonna have a program that
will be able to track everyone on earth
by their cell phone there is a drone
right above us nowhere
I just think life is so much more
colorful thanks to the the cognitive
prosthetics that we already have that
are in our pockets you know yeah and any
I don't know the more advanced and
efficient they can become and the more
that we can integrate them in a
meaningful way I think the better all
right there you have it so technology is
coming and hopefully we can use it for
some good but of course there's gonna be
some bad so let's not freak out how is
that I gave us a decent that was a dear
tubers yeah